[Musique]
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 politique sur tv fil 78 chaque chose
chaque semaine nous suivons la campagne
des législatives dans les yvelines
dernière ligne droite avant le premier
tour de scrutin le 11 juin avec
aujourd'hui 2 invités dans un instant
marie noëlle baal est candidate
socialiste dans la 12e circonscription
et puis déjà en plateau didier baichère
bonjour et genia de la république en
marche dans la première circonscription
des yvelines qui couvrent versailles
guyancourt ou encore monde signe un beau
peut-être déjà sur les premiers pas des
manuels macro entre l'affirmation sur la
scène internationale et puis aussi
quelques difficultés il faut bien le
souligner avec des soucis judiciaires
pour certains ministres comment vous
analysez ces premiers jours je pense
qu'on a un retour là moi je trouve que
depuis quinze jours on a des retours
extrêmement positif du terrain avec les
réunions publiques ont fait tous les
soirs la perception des manuels macro
extrêmement positive on le voit sur la
scène internationale je pense que là on
dit la france est de retour ça fait
plaisir
moi je voyage beaucoup à l'étranger pour
mon travail et je suis je suis content
de voir que la presse étrangère souligne
les actions du gouvernement et des
manuels maquereau en particulier donc
c'est plutôt une bonne chose
sur le volet judiciaire cette fois ci je
pense à de l' affaire richard ferrand
notamment après c'est compliqué mais je
suis pas juge donc je vais avoir du mal
à avoir un avis très tranché sur le
sujet on est sur des affaires qui sont
privés donc je pense qu'il faut pas tout
mélanger il n'y a pas de pas d'éléments
de financement public dans cette affaire
donc je pense que le le juge doit faire
son travail et puis on verra ce qu'il en
est mais ne mélangeons pas tous les
sujets mais ça peut semer le trouble
néanmoins alors qu'il ya cette voix de
moralisation qui se prépare
cll est important de cette fois de
moralisation ac c'est un des premiers
sujets qu'on avait travaillé dans l'est
dans les comités locaux en marche parce
qu'on voulait que le rôle des députés et
la manière d'exercer son rôle de députée
soit différent donc voilà maintenant
elle va voir le jour c'est le premier
dossier sur lequel on va travailler à
l'assemblée nationale c'est essentiel et
c'est ce qu'on entend dans le débat là
aussi un dans les réunions publiques
on veut bien vous faire confiance mais
cette fois ci on veut être sûr qu'on va
être entendu et que vous allez faire ce
que vous avez dit que vous ferez des
toilettes à bord de ses référents par
exemple est ce qu'il aurait dû il
devrait démissionner
pour justement mettre fin à ces
différentes polémiques et moi j'suis pas
le premier ministre ni le président de
la république c'est à vous de juger
l'équipe gouvernementale ce qui ce
qu'ils doivent faire encore une fois je
pense qu'on est sur une affaire privée
il n'y a pas d'argent public en jeu donc
nous mélangeons pas tout laissons la
justice faire son travail et richard
ferrand le sien aussi on verra s'il est
élu député ce que je crois cette
élection justement cette élection
législative est pour le moins troublant
en tout cas si on se risque au jeu des
projections et des résultats éventuels
difficile de savoir ce que les candidats
de la république en marche vont réussir
à totaliser est ce qu'il y aura ou non
cette majorité au moins au moins
majorité voire majorité absolue à
l'assemblée nationale est-ce que c'est
difficile sur le terrain et là pas
uniquement pour votre pour votre cas
mais pour l'ensemble des candidats
certains fonds sont moins connus aussi
dans certaines circonscriptions ils ont
beaucoup de travail à faire on n'a de
toutes façons beaucoup de travail à
faire sur une campagne
moi je pense qu'on est on effectivement
peut-être beaucoup de candidats moins
connus sur la première circonscription
des yvelines
notre objectif dans cette campagne nous
c'est d'être au travail je suis dans
l'action
lundi j'étais avec laura flessel la
ministre des sports hier j'étais chez
renault à l'invitation de la cfdt pour
travailler sur le nouveau modèle social
avec cédric villani qui m'accompagnait
également demain je rencontre les
médecins de différentes cliniques de la
circonscription pour parler de la santé
voilà notre travail pour être élu c'est
de comprendre le terrain comprendre les
enjeux de la circonscription et ça y'a
pas besoin d'être connus ou pas connus
je pense que les gens vous sollicitez ça
c'est un très bon point parce qu'ils
sentent qu'ils ont des candidats de la
république en marche qui ont envie de
travailler sur le terrain et d'être
pragmatique donc on est extrêmement
sollicité je trouve que c'est une très
bonne chose
vous êtes déjà élu à versailles dans
l'opposition dont vous connaissez déjà
aussi ce secteur et vous bénéficiez déjà
deux de ce petit capital de notoriété au
cours de ce scrutin
vous présente comment comme un candidat
aussi de la société civile oui oui moi
je suis drh à guyancourt
je travaille je continue à travailler
pendant la campagne ce qui est pas
toujours simple mais heureusement je
m'appuie sur les équipes qui sont
fréquentes
voilà et c'est une campagne de terrain
résolument on a voulu faire tous les
soirs on alterne montini guyancourt
versailles sur des réunions dans les
quartiers
pas de gros meetings et on parle avec
les gens on veut comprendre ce qui les
préoccupe au quotidien pour être sûr
qu'après l'assemblée nationale on sera
aussi des élus de terrain qui
retourneront vers eux pour expliquer la
pédagogie c'est quelque chose qui est
extrêmement important dans notre rôle de
député je compte beaucoup dessus pour
engager le territoire dans les réformes
on va regarder les résultats de la
présidentielle de cette dernière
présidentielle sur versailles notamment
emmanuel macron était en tête au second
tour largement mais si on se réfère au
premier tour sur versailles c'est
françois fillon qui totalisait plus de
40 45 % sur cet unique commune de
versailles
vous vous dites que c'est déjà joué en
pas du tout non pas du tout parce qu'en
plus il faut pas regarder que vers ça et
puis si on regarde l'ensemble de la
circonscription je crois que
la recomposer c-32 fillon et 30
macrophages vous 10 à 12 tonnes
je crois que l'écart de voix ces deux
mille voix est moins significatif c'est
vraiment et on est bien dans une
circonscription où il ya montini
guyancourt et versailles donc moi je
trouve que le jeu est très très très
ouvert
donc on continue à ne pas baisser les
bras à convaincre a rencontré à
comprendre je suis la tournée des
commerçants tous les jours et je rentre
dans chacune des boutiques et je passe
le temps qu'il faut pour discuter et
comprendre aussi les problématiques du
commerce local
donc je pense que c'est l'accueil est
bon et les jeux je sens le frémissement
en tout cas pour pour la république en
marche et je suis très très optimiste
françois de mazières et le député
sortant il a décidé de ne pas se
représenter en raison du cumul des
mandats il veut se consacrer à sa ville
de versailles où il est élu maire
cette françois-xavier bellamy qui a été
désigné pour lui succéder candidats les
républicains et udi
quel regard vous portez sur sept ce
passage de relais parce que je relisais
quelques interviews de vous vous parliez
d'un système féodal en termes de
succession oui oui parce que je crois
que c'est exactement ce qu'on veut plus
dans la politique à un moment donné
quelqu'un qui est en place
transmet son poste à quelqu'un enfin je
trouve que ça correspond tellement pas à
la demande du terrain alors est ce qu il
a des compétences par les compétences
enfin moi je vais je suis très admiratif
de l'engagement de monsieur bellamy à 30
ans j'avais pas l'engagement qu'ils la
voilà maintenant on a on partage
probablement pas du tout il dit les
mêmes valeurs dit la même expérience du
terrain
je suis quelqu'un dans l'action et ça va
faire la différence et c'est évident le
programme en ce qui vous concerne emploi
éducation défense sécurité défense de la
candidature des jeux olympiques j'ai
résumé ruyant cinq points il ya deux
circonscriptions on peut s'attarder
peut-être sur cette question d'éducation
notamment parce que ça aussi ça fait
partie des chantiers prioritaires pour
emmanuel macron avec quelques
ajustements la réforme des rythmes
scolaires aussi par exemple comment vous
allez la porter dans cette
circonscription si vous êtes élu ça y
est on est dedans
chacune des communes jeu
j'ai vu que montigné donc avait relancé
un questionnaire auprès de la population
pour avoir leur avis sur les rythmes qui
était en place et donc mesuré 6,6 à
l'échangé j'ai vu que versailles aussi
au seuil est là dans l'est dans les
conseils d'école s'était lancé dans la
discussion pour revenir à la semaine de
quatre jours
donc je pense que chacune des communes a
saisi l'opportunité d'être opérationnel
dès le mois de septembre c'est la
volonté du ministre de l'éducation
nationale c'est ce qu'on avait prévu
dans le programme des manuels macron et
c'est ce que laissait la liberté oui
laisser la liberté en fait de chacune
des communes dès l'instant on est dans
la concertation
moi ce que j'avais beaucoup reproché
dans cette affaire en tant que
conseiller municipal à versailles c'est
la non concertation c'est avec un moment
d on attend on ne parle pas avec les
écoles on parle pas avec les parents et
puis on laisse penser que c'est le
gouvernement qui impose la méthode est
différente aujourd'hui
avec emmanuel macron c'est du
pragmatisme du terrain de l' échange de
la concertation et c'est ça qui va
marcher sur la clé de sur le secteur de
l'emploi sur ce point-clé de de l'emploi
sur cette circonscription quels sont les
laits les dossiers prioritaires qui
pourrait vous préoccuper en tant que
député on a la chance d'avoir 1,4
emplois sur par habitant sur la
circonscription donc un niveau d'emplois
beaucoup plus élevé par habitant après
quand je regarde d'une ville à l'autre
on va avoir entre 30 et 37 % des gens
qui habitent saint quentin où qu'ils
habitent versailles et qui qui
travaillent dans notre circonscription
je pense qu'on fait on peut faire mieux
sur l'emploi local
c'est le débat que nous avions eue hier
j'étais chez renault à l'invitation de
de la cfdt pour travailler là dessus et
regarder comment un employeur aussi
important peut s'assurer qu'il joue
aussi son rôle de moteur économique
local c'est bon pour l'écologie au
silence que s'il ya plus de gens qui
travaillent dans la circonscription se
déplacent moins on a une meilleure
qualité de vie personnelle familiale
donc on a tous à y gagner
et là moi je le vois en tant que drh sur
la circonscription à guyancourt
on manque souvent d'interlocuteurs
public pour arriver à trouver la réponse
à nos questions toucher les bons
étudiants ou les bons demandeur d'emploi
pour pour les faire accéder aux postes
pour lesquels on recrute là il ya une
action de médiation ou le député a toute
sa place et c'est ça que je je mènerai
sur sur les territoires il ya des
discussions qui sont en cours avec les
différents syndicats justement là je
parle au niveau du gouvernement sur
cette réforme du droit du travail et
quelques quelques pistes du gouvernement
qui ont fuité comme on dit dans la
presse tous les syndicats ne sont pas en
tout cas pas dire ça comme ça satisfait
de ce qui pourrait se mettre en place
vous pensez que la concertation va bien
se passer quels sont les points
importants aussi sur lesquels il faut
revoir les choses
donc là maintenant le débat et des
publics puisque le premier ministre et
et muriel pénicaud là là là ministre du
travail dans coco communiqué hier sur le
calendrier sur le contenu du calendrier
on sait qu'on va avoir trois blocs de
négociations que la concertation
s'engage en parle d'une cinquantaine de
réunions avec un cadencement pendant
l'été pour le premier bloc de réformes
si on aura du travail et sur les
nouvelles mesures la baisse des charges
en tout cas pour tous les salariés avec
un objectif de fin septembre
on est sur le deuxième blog tout ce qui
est lié à la sécurisation des parcours
professionnels
l'apprentissage la formation qui aura
lieu d'ici le mois d'avril 2010 8 et le
dernier bloc qui est sur l'équité en
terme de retraite d'ici à la fin de 2018
donc le calendrier connu encore une fois
j'en veux pour preuve que hier après
l'annonce on avait rendez-vous après
l'annonce on était déjà en tout cas nous
députés en marche donc la cinquième 5ème
circonscription pour cédric villani et
première circonscription des yvelines
pour moi avec des représentants du
personnel
qu'est ce qu'ils pensent
de la délégation unique qu'est ce qu'ils
pensent du référendum minoritaires voilà
nous ont interpellés sur l'ensemble de
ces sujets et on peut on peut être dans
l'action et c'est le rôle du député
c'est à dire que maintenant le débat va
s'engager et nous on va pouvoir faire
remonter aussi le le besoin du terrain
je l histoire de la délégation unique du
personnel est très intéressant vous êtes
chez renault qui est une entreprise avec
une historique du dialogue social
bien entendu que ce sujet-là peut
manquer d'intérêt par contre pour une
entreprise beaucoup plus petit
la multiplicité des instances et
compliqué à gérer pour un entrepreneur
donc là il faudra simplifiée voilà c'est
ça qu'on mène il faudra que tout ça
passe devant les députés au cours d'un
vote os qu'une ensuite une ordonnance à
1 49 3
alors là on va sur les ordonnances ça a
été annoncé très très clairement aussi
hier par le premier ministre le principe
de l' ordonnance d'experts une chose que
le 49 3 ans et il n'empêche pas la
concertation on veut juste éviter les
allers retours permanents entre
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat et
être sûr que dès le 1er janvier
en tout cas la baisse de charges pour
les salariés sera bien en place et on
veut s'assurer que le droit du travail
est adapté aux salariés d'aujourd'hui et
aux modes de travail d'aujourd'hui et ça
si on attend la fin du quinquennat et un
débat extrêmement long on l'a vu par le
passé ça donne pas du tout de bons
résultats donc mais c'est la
concertation ses manières - oui mais de
voter nous aimons les relations
professionnelles terre on demandera à
l'assemblée si elle est d'accord pour
confier les ordonnances sur le système
ordonnance mais la concertation et le
début tout de suite ça y est on est en
concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux
juste pour terminer cet entretien il
nous reste quelques minutes si un
dossier commun à ces trois communes là
c'est celui que vous avez souligné dans
votre projet c'est la candidature des
jeux olympiques oui comment en tant que
député ensuite si vous êtes élu vous
pouvez vous impliquez essentiel
l'appareil dans l'action lundi après
midi j'ai passé toute l'après-midi avec
laura flessel où on a pu débattre en
fait de deux choses importantes dans
cette candidature c'est comment on peut
mettre en avant mieux le handicap dans
notre dans notre cas particulier parce
que j'en ai souvent parlé il ya des
choses en matière de périscolaire autour
du sport pour les enfants handicapés qui
sont faites sur notre circonscription et
qui doit faire partie de leur dû dossier
de candidature et aussi parce que c'est
une opportunité populaire familiale on a
on a des quartiers plus populaires aussi
dans notre circonscription et laura
flessel est très très sensibles à ça
pour rien vous cacher on a une visite
du vélodrome qui est prévu en milieu de
semaine prochaine je croise les doigts
et s'est engagée bon jeu peut-être
qu'elle aura du mal à tenir le
calendrier en tout cas moi j'y serai
pour cette visite et on voit apparaître
dans l'action je soutiens j'agis je
discute je présente la circonscription
c'est extrêmement important est
convaincu que cette candidature aux jeux
olympiques pour pour parier et donc
saint quentin en yvelines et versailles
également est une bonne chose c'est une
excellente chose on va on va aussi
capter un moment donné je voyais que les
commerçants sur certains centres
commerciaux sur montigny je pense qu'on
va capter aussi du financement pour
faire de la rénovation c'est une très
bonne chose pour la population merci
didier baichère on va voir la liste des
candidats dans cette 1re circonscription
des yvelines qui va s'afficher
vous le voyez ils sont nombreux là aussi
à se présenter premier tour de scrutin
le 11 juin le 7-8 politique se poursuit
dans un instant à marie noëlle bas
candidate socialiste dans la 12e
circonscription pour l'instant
présentation d'une autre candidate de
cette circonscription
florence grand juhel portent les
couleurs de la république en marche
justement
une femme de terrain c'est comme cela
que se définit florence grand juge
assistant à la direction générale de
pôle emploi
elle s'est engagée en politique auprès
de la république en marche pour les
législatives
candidate dans la 12e circonscription
elle veut faire de l'emploi sa priorité
un domaine qu'elle connaît depuis 30 ans
j'ai donc été directrice d'agencé sur
différentes implantations des yvelines
et j'ai créé également la chance pour
l'emploi de plaisir en 2001 vous
permettent aux plaisirs war également
aux habitants de ben et saint germain de
la grange d'avoir un service pour
l'emploi de proximité l'emploi permet de
toucher tous les sujets et depuis
maintenant deux ans je travaille auprès
du directeur général adjoint de pôle
emploi issu de la société civile c'est
sa première expérience en politique mais
c'est un environnement qui lui est
familier j'ai l'habitude de travailler
avec les politiques
j'ai commencé tout jeune son département
des yvelines j'ai travaillé avec de
nombreuses personnalités politiques et
c'est particulièrement important
lorsque l'on travaille dans le domaine
de l'emploi qui est un sujet très
sensible de pouvoir travailler avec tous
les acteurs locaux
il fallait ouvrir à la société civile
l'assemblée nationale parce que la
politique je pense que c'est pas un
métier pour l'épauler dans sa campagne
son suppléant aymeric vallespir un
travail qu'elle veut complémentaire
c'est avec lui qu'elle a défini son
programme axé sur l'éducation la
sécurité ou les transports enrique et
trés trés par son parcours professionnel
dans sa jeunesse son appétence également
bien on dirait je dirais qu'il est
vraiment la personne qui peut le mieux
compléter ma candidature
aujourd'hui nous faisons campagne
ensemble nous rencontrons les personnes
ensemble nous avons construit donc les
axones of au programme ensemble est
également et bien notre réflexion et
contré quotidiennement florence granger
affrontera très autre candidat pour
cette élection
parmi eux le député sortant républicain
david douillet élu à près de 50 fois
pour cent en 2012
nous retiendrons ce cette suite
politique toujours dans la 12e
circonscription qui couvre notamment
plaisir vous encore poissy avec marie
noëlle bas bonjour et bienvenue sur ce
plateau
vous êtes candidate socialiste donc 30 à
40 sièges pour le parti socialiste en
france dans la prochaine assemblée ce
sont les dernières projections des
instituts de sondage
est ce que vous êtes inquiète quant à
l'avenir de votre formation je rappelle
tout de même aujourd'hui sur l'assemblée
sortante il y à 2 195 députés
socialistes oui bien sûr on peut
effectivement être inquiet mais le but
n'est pas ça le but est d'essayer de
faire prospérer nos idées nos idées de
solidarité de justice sociale de partage
est en fait il faut attendre de voir ce
que les électeurs et les électrices vont
décider on les rencontre beaucoup dans
les gares dans les marchés et l'intérêt
c'est effectivement de parler avec eux
de savoir ce qu'il ce qu'ils nous disent
et de pouvoir éventuellement si jamais
je suis élu les les retransmettre au
moment de propositions de loi ou de oud
ou d'amendements et bien un risque de
marginalisation du parti socialiste je
me base sur les résultats de la
présidentielle dans votre
circonscription 7 61% pour benoît hamon
ça c'est sûr poissy ou encore 8,18 % au
premier tour sur la commune de plaisir
on le voit là ce sont des scores très
décevant pour le parti socialiste
oui oui c'est très décevant mais on le
sait aussi pourquoi c'est arrivé
le parti socialiste a trahi le candidat
qui était à la présidentielle enfin une
partie en tout cas du parti socialiste
et d'autre part est parti un certain
nombre de socialistes sont partis à la
république en marche
donc nous nous continuons à défendre nos
idées parce que nous pensons nous sommes
même sûr qu'elles sont meilleures pour
l'avenir de nos enfants l'avenir des
plus précaires d'entre nous votre
ambition à vous pendant cette
législative c'est d'atteindre le second
tour décroché une triangulaire comment
vous positionnez comment vous envisagez
bien entendu c'est l'ambition c'est
toujours de réussir je pars gagnante
mais la vraie ambition de notre équipe
et de toutes les équipes de ps2 l'a12 et
de la discipline c'est bien évidemment
de faire partager nos idées et de et de
dire ce que ce qu'on souhaite pour
l'avenir sur le fond est ce que le
programme du parti socialiste et est
clair pour ce scrutin législatif je vous
demande ça par rapport aux aménagements
qui a pu avoir du projet et qui avaient
été portées par benoît hamon ou
aujourd'hui vous défendez toujours ce
projet présidentiel
c'est tout à fait clair je continue à
défendre le projet présidentiel de
benoît hamon bien évidemment qui était
le seul qui était extrêmement novateur
qui avait une vision sur l'avenir sur
l'avenir du travail sur les changements
de société sur l'avenir de
l'environnement qui est extrêmement
important aujourd'hui et on parle
beaucoup plus d'économies qui est très
important bien sûr mais qui ne doit pas
être une finalité mais qui doit être un
moyen pour que la vie de chacune et
chacun soit meilleur donc vous êtes
convaincus que ce programme était le bon
même s'il n'a pas rencontré le succès
escompté lors du scrutin précédent c'est
je suis tout à fait convaincu que ce
programme était le bon et d'ailleurs on
le voit à la lecture
différentes eux
tribune de vos confrères benoît hamon a
souffert des dissensions au ps de la
dynamique dedans marche de la dynamique
de jean luc mélenchon mais évidemment un
certain nombre disent que son projet
était le seul novateur puisque justement
il ne s'appuyait pas sur de vieilles
recettes comme le font tous les autres
pour les autres partis certains
candidats du parti socialiste se disent
mâcon compatible s'il était élu il
siégerait plutôt du côté de la majorité
présidentielle à vous écouter sera
pardon clairement pas notre cas il est
évident qu'en tant que personnes de la
société civile et et militante depuis
des années je trouve que c'est très
important de ne pas voter des lois ou
des amendements qui sont préjudiciables
au bien commun mais bien évidemment s'il
y a des aménagements législatifs qui
peuvent être intéressants pour la
population il pas question que je ne les
vois pas bien évidemment quel regard
vous portez sur les débuts de la
présidence d' emmanuel macron sceptiques
bien sûr
c'est quand même une présidence très
marketing avec beaucoup d'éléments de
langage avec quand même quelques zones
d'ombré aujourd'hui il ne me semble pas
que les françaises et les français
puissent se décider sur le code du
travail puisque finalement tout est
extrêmement floues on nous dit que ça
fait dur mais pour l'instant personne ne
sait exactement ce qui va se passer
donc non le code du travail le fait de
baisser les budgets publics
moi je suis en défense des services
publics les services publics sont le
patrimoine de celles et ceux qui n'en
n'ont pas pour moi c'est extrêmement
important de défendre les services
publics donc enlevé 120 mille
fonctionnaires et baisser le budget me
paraît une erreur et un vrai problème
encore une fois pour les plus précaires
quel est le point de programme s'il y en
avait un que vous souhaiteriez défendre
le plus à l'assemblée en cas de victoire
qui me concerne
quel est votre projet vous pourriez
porter et notamment au regard des enjeux
de la 12e circonscription les services
publics
d'évidence le délai déserts médicaux
dans notre département qui commence à
être vraiment important donc je le redis
les services publics oui le fait d'avoir
des services publics à moins de 30
minutes de chez soi ça me semble
absolument indispensable défendre le
code du travail parce que bien sûr moi
je suis plutôt du côté des salariés que
du côté des patrons même des petites
entreprises
il me semble extrêmement important de
défendre les droits des salariés
et puis l'écologie l'environnement la
défense de l'air de l'eau
la lutte contre les perturbateurs
endocriniens la lutte contre les
pesticides tout ça on en parle assez peu
or c'est notre survie dont il s'agit la
12e circonscription est partagé entre
réalité grandes villes également
aujourd'hui tout cela peut cohabiter
coexister au regard des propositions
vous faites bien évidemment je viens de
parler des services publics dans la dans
les endroits les plus ruraux
c'est là que se posent les problèmes des
services publics et puis c'est
effectivement plus tôt dans les grandes
villes que se posent les problèmes
environnementaux
mais par exemple les problèmes des
perturbateurs endocriniens où les
problèmes des d2 delà de la malbouffe
ça se fasse cesser partout dans les
villes comme dans les campagnes
il nous reste quelques instants de
conclure cet entretien vous présentait
donc dans la 12e circonscription marie
noël bat pour vous présenter un petit
peu mieux vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure que vous étiez de la société
civile donc vous présenter un petit peu
plus aux électeurs
eh bien j'ai travaillé dans la
communication d'événements culturels
pendant des années je suis en retraite
active depuis quelques semaines je donne
des coups de main à des start up en
communication et en organisation et je
suis militante féministe c'est votre
premier combat politique tisme
alors la candidature j'ai été candidate
à des élections cantonales et j'ai été
conseillère municipale pendant six ans à
poissy mais dans la majorité
et aujourd'hui on tente de politique
qu'est ce qui vous plaît dans le
programme du parti socialiste est ce que
vous vous y retrouver pleinement puisque
après et ce sera ma dernière question je
vous demanderais si il faudrait une
refondation du parti socialiste donc
pourquoi vous vous retrouvez au sein du
parti socialiste et alors je reste au
parti socialiste mais je vous ai
confirmé que j'étais je suivais plus le
programme de benoît hamon que le
programme du parti socialiste
donc je reste je reste absolument
derrière le député et ex candidat à la
présidentielle de noirmont et candidat
dans la 11e circonscription des yvelines
je le rappelle également et donc cette
question est-ce qu'il faudra à l'issue
des législatives
quel que soit le résultat au final une
refondation du ps pour clarifier les
choses entre les différentes branches
bien évidemment sachant que la plupart
de ceux qui étaient macro compatibles
sont partis chez makro ou de ceux qui
refusaient le
finalement ce que le quinquennat a fait
de peu à gauche puisqu'il faut quand
même rappeler qu'il n'ya jamais eu
autant de logements sociaux que soul
contest le quinquennat de hollande
néanmoins il ya eu le cic eux le
l'éventualité de la déchéance de
nationalité
et ceux là sont plutôt partie chez
mélenchon il reste une garde derrière
benoît hamon qui continue à défendre ses
idées puisque encore une fois elle nous
semble progressistes et les meilleurs
pour notre pays
merci marie noëlle bas candidat donc
dans la 12e circonscription si on peut
revoir la liste de ceux qui ceux et
celles qui se présentent dans cette
circonscription des yvelines et le
député sortant également david douillet
et qui brigue un nouveau mandat
nous refermons le 7-8 politique c'était
la dernière édition avant le vote du
premier tour le 11 juin pour suivre les
résultats rendez-vous dès 19h30 en
direct sur notre antenne pour la grande
soirée électorale une émission qui sera
diffusée en simultané sur radio
sensations hervé eux dans le sud des
yvelines ou encore bpm menthe dans le
nord du département à très bientôt
[Musique]